It's very important to align all
the different stakeholders towards
that same goals.
First, everyone needs to have a shared
view on what the current situation is.
What are the goals?
What are the current practices and
flows?
All of the stakeholders
should participate and
work together to
formulate the end goals.
Shared input generally creates
shared responsibility and ownership.
People are willing to work
together if their thoughts and
opinions are being heard.
It's important to have a shared
view on problems and identify and
eliminate bottlenecks.
The bottlenecks can be inside
departments or between them.
It's not really important as
long as they're being addressed.
And it's also important to have
shared benefits amongst the team.
You want to make sure that you have
all the involved stakeholders get
the benefit of a new product release.
To achieve that you need to define and
measure key performance indicators for
the whole cross functional team.
You cannot improve what
you cannot measure.